so i want to start with uh just a thank
you uh i watched all eight episodes i
was laughing like a crazy person and i
just want to say thank you because uh it
was great i just i had such a blast with
it thank you thank you so happy you did
awesome you got them all great oh yeah
let's talk about i'm just going to make
a joke about let's just talk spoilers
but no yeah and without spoiling i will
say it's one of my favorite
endings
of
anything
that's that's that's why it is spoiling
it's not just let people know that
there's an ending
[Laughter]
i do want to start with a big thank you
to peacock for letting you guys make
this uh i always wanted more mcgruber
and i just want to say thanks to them as
well um before we get into mcgruber yeah
we are so
i just want to add on that like they
they've been so great and and we're so
appreciative
we never
you know we never knew if anybody would
give us a chance to do this and and
they've they they've stepped up and and
let you really
really
trusted our
sicko brains to uh you know to
to put this thing together and they've
been awesome partners in this and we
love them yeah and they definitely let
you get away with a lot of stuff uh it
is brutally violent it is a hard r
and it is definitely unlike anything
else on tv without a doubt yep yes
so if some
different questions other than mcgruber
i want to start with for both of you if
someone has actually never seen anything
that you've done before what is the
first thing you want them watching and
why
oh my gosh
i guess for me it would probably be snl
just because that's kind of where i
started and i feel like
being there for so long and being able
to
i don't know i feel like that's the most
me
um
if that makes sense just because that's
sort of like where i
began
that's a very interesting question i
know yeah i don't know how i would
answer that
um
yeah i i mean i i certainly if
the mcgruber movie would would be oh
yeah i mean
yeah yeah mcgruber movie no no no but i
mean snl
excuse me
um
you know obviously this this came as a
direct result of snl i mean it was you
know the character was born there so
that's you know i think that's a great a
great answer too i don't i yeah i don't
know
but i will say like as far as like
something besides that that is my sense
of humor mcgruber definitely falls in
that like
it's just very much
my sense of humor
it's interesting because then i go oh
well what the the answer is very
different if i'm thinking about
um
my
i just had a a baby
uh 10 months ago about 10 months ago
that my wife did um but i was there
and uh and then i think about what would
i want her to see
um because it would not be wouldn't even
brew right now but i don't know but uh
maybe the the movie nebraska yes just
wanted to get out there that i was in
uh the movie nebraska
so yeah so i attacked i
asked myself a different version of your
question so i could get that out there
oscar
not me myself but the movies that i was
in
nebraska
we'll move on to the next thing i um
for both of you though what was your
reaction when you heard that christopher
nolan was such a huge fan of magruber
and would quote it on the set of the of
the dark knight rises
well i would say probably the same way i
felt when i got to be in the movie
nebraska
just
couldn't believe it
here's this
oscar-nominated
film no i'm kidding
i i mean
it was if i didn't see
if i didn't see anne hathaway talking
about that on a talk show i would have
not believed that that was
i mean i knew about cr i didn't know
that and
yeah i think she was on a talk show and
she she had
mentioned something about she knew when
when he was in a good mood because he
would be talking about mcgruber it's not
something like that and it was
it's it's it's shocking and one of the
lotteries great
the greatest filmmakers of all time and
so it was it
made me revisit some of his work in
question questionnaire a little bit i'm
like what does this guy what's his taste
really like
oh i i don't want to talk spoilers but
at some point in this series uh you two
have to deactivate something together
and the scene i think people are
expecting that
the the scene is uh sorry for my
language it's [ __ ] great and the
sexual tension and the like the fact of
like what you two are doing how hard is
it to not break when you are filming a
scene like that because
me watching it i just i could never film
that i could never be an actor in that
scene it's very hard i will say
and this might not even make sense but
because we're playing it so dramatically
it kind of lends itself to like you're
not really being you're
that's kind of hard to explain but i
think because we're being sort of like
over the top serious
it's harder to get into that laughing
mode but when we rehearse it and when
we're done it's like yeah you know it's
and it's very hard it's it's there's
something about
making like in your head you're also
like
trying to remember your lines and and so
they're all these things you got to
remember where to go and when to do this
so there's so much you're thinking about
that a lot of times you you can't
you you're just so focused on other
stuff that you're not
in
able to enjoy the other person's
performance in the same way that you
would
uh maybe watching it or or like it's
there are definitely scenes where you
don't have a lot of lines like when we
do those
sex scenes it's so dumb it is so
it is
there's a lot of laughing during that
just because we are being so dumb with
each other and you can hear other people
laughing too which makes it which kind
of like takes the any awkwardness that
would be there yeah oh man
and it's just like oh how like
i just feel so bad for her when we're in
those scenes although this time i didn't
sweat on you as much that's true oh
that's a spoiler there's no sex scene in
this
there's no sex scene in this
sex
i i have i honestly i i
people next door must have thought i was
a crazy person during that scene when i
was watching you too because i was
laughing so hard but um will i i
definitely want to talk to you because
you're obviously one of the writers
you're instrumental in this series and
and i want to say honestly you are
so fearless on this show
and the way that like you are writing
yourself to being naked like every other
scene
that you bring that up because i i just
in my head remember all the times and
i'm like are we sure that i need to be
naked in this one
yeah we i kind of
we'd have this awesome writing staff and
and and we all would would um come up
with this stuff together and and write
it out and then you you know you
peck away you chip away at stuff and you
tighten it up and you punch up stuff but
you know all the time you're looking for
you're you're just questioning each
scene is there a way to make it better
is there is this the best version of it
and and i i you know i do remember
i think all of us were like
are people
that excited to see your naked body that
that
we're going to continue like are we get
because i'm basically naked the entire
second episode
and
it's not
i don't have like
a body that people like to look at oh
stop
but can i but he was you are not
i mean but you are very fearless and not
even just in the
naked stuff but as a performer in your
like he was saying like you know i mean
maybe i'll just let you
finish oh well i appreciate that he's
caught i want you to take this
compliment oh thank you well i i
appreciate you saying that it's
he is you know incredibly we work really
hard on the script and and and when when
we've all decided this is what we're
gonna do i i just do what i'm told and
uh and sometimes i've
you know written some of those things
also so i just you know once we all
decide this is i think what this scene
should be i i just
i you know i go do it and sometimes i'm
i'm not as fearless as you i do it but
like you know i'm just i get shy like
anybody else it's it's uh
um but but you just do what you gotta do
i guess
uh
i'm just gonna say i really mean it
thank you so much for making this series
i really hope it's a huge hit because i
would love to see more um thank you
thank you for your time i really
appreciate it talking to you thank you
for all the nice things you said yeah
thanks